[Music]
this is branch Whismur sports racing
sponsored by placing Lauren's first of
all congratulations to make it to the
final 30 to 80 so now it's you against
me yes
I would say I'd like to watch you but
I'd not sure I'm gonna be able to for
very long because they'd all be in front
have you seen the GTR from behind no get
just don't I see so this was like a
pretty technical track what's something
that we can all like think about while
watching you drive that maybe we can
appreciate a little boy I think you can
pay attention a lot on braking technique
the way we break you could see we go
hard on the brakes in the beginning and
then we start going off because there's
no downforce anymore on the racing we
use shoe very very slim to have more
feedback from the braking pedal so
you'll see if I Drive without shoes and
at the end of the day it's about having
fun about enjoying what you do there's a
lot of pressure a lot of risk when
you're racing in real life but you have
to enjoy what you do so just just relax
and let's see who wins
[Music]
what are the chances that Lauren's
pulses Oh zero
[Music]
probably bet on how much we think
Lawrence is gonna lose by I'm gonna say
50 seconds 50 seconds again my is my can
let's say 65 seconds just wanna come in
within a minute I'm giving myself a
minute Lawrence really get aggressive if
he can knock him out
crash him that's his hope that Ricardo
can't finish the race
it's not reclose so large oh man
come on Lawrence weak so fast I can't
see you man hey let's trash talking
begin
oh there he comes oh you dipped up much
better on the straightaways that's a
good turnout I think I got a little bit
on you on that corner but it's gonna
it's gonna disappear soon Ricardo's
conditioned for 300 kilometer races so
you have to worry about fatigue setting
in
anyway I heard that's okay I'll catch up
along that I'm working on right now
Lawrence appears to be eight seconds
behind
[Music]
[Applause]
hey nice correction that's the first lap
we give you a time check right here no I
see you up there four seconds behind
Lawrence cut down that time it's kind of
close lawrence is catching on yes
definitely
oh thank you for slowing down oh we got
a little too greedy he saw my yeah I
know that feeling where you see him and
then you think oh come on Lawrence I'm
trying I'm trying got a recent Irma
chakras look at this recovery it's still
pretty close we were way off on our
prediction yeah mr. ft Lawrence's
travelers is easing some techniques
turn that goddamn last time
[Applause]
course is still making good time he's
still within one second of it just so
the viewers now that Ricardo is also
using the paddle shifters I was watching
him race after I had already lost he's
using the whole steering wheel the knobs
on the steering wheel
I'd miss it the air not just not with
you yeah I thought I thought don't what
to do that yeah we're coming up on the
last lap down
I'm sorry little blue I think there's a
little bump action Lawrence is getting
desperate no this is the turn-up this is
Lawrence's turn he's
I think it was advantageous for him to
be behind that right there slowed him
down only a couple more turns there's
one turn left and I have to really nail
it cut off those angles
Oh wah wah this close that was extremely
gosh
[Music]
well don't man thank you for making it
interesting this has been a racing
experience unlike anything I've ever had
before hope to see you again maybe
online racing maybe real racing who
knows people look up for the arsonist
ups thanks for everything good luck in
the future
for more information on Gran Turismo
sport click on the link
you